[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
garçon garçon s'il vous plaît je
voudrais un café crème avec deux croix
sable je m'excuse monsieur nous n'avons
plus du tout de croix simple ah ben ça
fait rien alors je vais prendre d'autres
choses
ça fait en a tellement dans nuit entre
nous un chacun dans sa vie privée on n'a
que des soucis l on va pas ça en fait un
entraînement avec à me donner un café
nature à leur café nature avec deux
croient ça
je m'excuse je ne suis peut-être pas
l'exprimer je vous dis qu'on y croit ça
nous n'avons plus on n'a plus du tout
croissant là ça change tout si on a plus
je peux pas en avoir forcément ça fait
rien je parle d'autre chose alors je
prends n'importe quoi du lait et du les
données - dans une tasse de lait avec
2,3 ça ça va pas vous êtes un peu
fatigué ou non je vous dis que les
croissants on n'en n'avons plus c'est ce
que c'est qu'il croise un décroissant
des bretzels des brioches oui
décroissant non faut pas vous énervez
pour ça mais ça fait rien écoutez je
suis pas le client beta je vous dire
donnez moi ce que vous voulez je peux
pas mieux vous dire du thé et du
chocolat chaud à 2 croise à damas et ont
longtemps habité ce garçon je vous
connais pas moi je suis client monsieur
je suis comme vous j'étais derrière la
colonne vous m'avez peut-être pas vu
mais moi je vous ai entendu d'autres pas
malade lankais ce qui vous pend dans un
petit garçon et gna gna gna gna gna gna
tgv
laissez moi vous dire monsieur que vous
avez de la chance d'avoir à faire un
garçon qui a de la patience parce que -
garçons si j'avais à votre place il ya
longtemps que j'aurais pris les deux
croissants chauds les oreilles situe sur
la gueule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]